on le disait le collectif contre
l'islamophobie en france est donc
menacée de dissolution par le
gouvernement accusé de proximité avec l
islam politique l'association nie en
bloc et les noms je cite des calomnies
d'une incroyable indécence compte tenu
du contexte alors le ccf qui se dit
apolitique et areligieuse est il
impossible ennemis de la république
comme l'a décrit le ministre de
l'intérieur a c'est l'objet de notre
face à face et pour en débattre nous
sommes avec gaëtan du soc est membre du
conseil national du rassemblement
national bonsoir à vos côtés loïc
prud'hommes député la france insoumise
troisième circonscription de gironde
bonsoir
alors on le disait le ccf dans le
collimateur du gouvernement alors on va
le rappeler en collectif se présente
comme une association de défense des
droits humains et elle vise à lutter
contre l'islamophobie en apportant une
aide juridique aux personnes de victimes
d'actes islamophobes
alors quand le ministre de l'intérieur
parle du ccf comme d'un ennemi de la
république
est-ce que vous rejoignez ses propos
gaëtan du sausset mais je rejoins ses
propos et malheureusement ils sont un
peu tardif parce que gérald darmanin
est-ce que l'on peut regretter
et finalement comme le gouvernement et
le président de la république obligés
d'attendre qu'il y ait des morts obligés
d'attendre qu'il y ait des astros cette
atrocité pardon et des actes commis avec
une barbarie intense pour prendre des
décisions
le ccis est pas nouveau est à une
organisation qui est lié aux frères
musulmans et frères musulmans est une
organisation elle-même islamistes qui
défend une idéologie idéologie de
fondamentalisme islamiste et qui à de
nombreuses reprises déclaré
comment dire ont mis en avant un agent
d'un politique est allé complètement à
l'encontre de nos valeurs et à
l'encontre de notre pays
donc c'est très bien qu'il le fasse
maintenant il aurait peut-être fallu le
faire plus tôt mais malheureusement ça
ne suffira pas il y voit il faut
dissoudre ccf oui il faut dissoudre
barak a city je pense qu'il faut aussi
se poser la question concernant d'autres
organisations contre liège mais même si
ces mesures sont bonnes il y en a
évidemment un tas d'autres qui va
falloir mettre en oeuvre par la suite
loïc prud'hommes on se souvient que le
10 novembre 2009 2019 votre parti
marcher aux côtés du ccf pour dénoncer
l'islamophobie
pour jean luc mélenchon le message
véhiculé par la manifestation était plus
important que les personnes qui
participaient est-ce que c'était une
erreur pour vous devrez rappeler que le
10 novembre nous marchions aux côtés de
la cgt de la fsu qui aujourd'hui un
rassemblement autour de samuel bâti
autour de attaque et autour de toute
cette gauche qui ne renoncez pas à faire
que les valeurs de la république soit
soit préservée comme matisse pas une
partie de notre population je voudrais
dire que pour moi le g ralement darmanin
se placent sur sur un terrain qui est
sur un registre qui n'est pas le bon
vous savez il ya une constante sur les
affaires de terrorisme c'est qu'il faut
quand on est un responsable politique
agir avec sang-froid méthodes et quand
il fait des appels à dire la peur doit
changer de camp
il faut sidéré ceux qui nous ont sidéré
je voudrais rappeler que notre force de
la force de la république c'est le
respect du droit et donc il faut
absolument se placer dans ce respect de
la loi parce que sinon ça va être des
effets d'annoncé et in fine et je crains
que tout ça n'aboutisse pas donc je
pense que nous avons l'arsenal suffisant
16 loi antiterroriste depuis 30 ans a
fait une tous les deux ans et il faut
maintenant scruter vraiment avec
attention toutes les associations et sur
des faits et pas sur des présomptions ou
sur la mauvaise humeur du moment où sur
l'émotion de monsieur darmanin scruter
celle qui pose des problèmes dans le
cadre de la loi telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui parce que ce que veulent ces
gens ces terroristes
c'est aussi nous amener sur un terrain
qui n'est plus celui des lois de la
république les lois de la république qui
nous assure aujourd'hui de pouvoir vivre
ensemble donc c'est ça que je voudrais
rappeler et donc nous on est constant on
a été tout à fait cohérent et constant
nous étions à la marche en mémoire
amérique ne nous étions le 10 novembre
contre l'islamophobie et nous étions en
bourse ce dimanche massive
pour les rassemblements pour la mémoire
de samuel papier vous voyez que nous
sommes cohérents constant et que les
gens qui cherchent à nous faire à nous
livrer à la vindicte pour sur des
fausses des fausses vérités en fait
utilisent les mêmes les mêmes méthodes
que ce qu'il prétend de bon dans des
étangs du show c'est quand vous vous
entendez le prud'homme dire bah voilà
les les lois suffisent aujourd'hui pour
combattre le terrorisme islamiste qu'est
ce que vous répondez non mais bien sûr
je dirais pour le coup on a un arsenal
juridique assez suffisance la seule
chose qui manque c'est une volonté
politique pour les mettre en oeuvre
et oui il est vrai aujourd'hui la loi
existe et pas besoin de nouvelles lois
pour expulser tous les fichiers s est
rangé pour radicalisation y a pas besoin
de nouvelles lois pour expulser les
imams qui prêchent la haine qui prêchent
la haine des juifs et la haine des
homosexuels la haine des femmes
à longueur de prêches il n'y a pas
besoin de nouvelle loi on peut le faire
mais encore faut-il vouloir le faire et
c'est tout le problème de du
gouvernement et du président de la
république
ensuite moi j'entends bien ce que disait
monsieur le député mais il ya un moment
donné je lisais une langue n'êtes pas
cohérent et vous êtes juste très embêté
avec les différentes positions que vous
avez prises tantôt par idéologie tantôt
par intérêt électoraliste mais vous êtes
très embêté ce qu'il n'y a aucune
cohérence à aller manifester avec le ccf
avec les islamistes
avec des personnes qui font hurler à la
wac bas à quelques mètres du bataclan et
de l'autre côté d'aller ensuite à une
allée à une manifestation où cet
islamisme a tué louvre qui livrent des
armes à monsieur cou n'allait répondre
elle prudemment on n'a pas entendu le
début de votre intervention
non mais je trouve assez extraordinaire
de prendre des leçons de cohérence de
monsieur dissocier je voudrais que quand
même rappeler que monsieur claude
hermant et
du service d'ordre du front national
qu'il est celui qui a fourni les ordres
des armes à monsieur coulibaly pour
faire le massacre c'est fou que c'est un
hasard un adhérent dur dur du
rassemblement national qui a fait une
filiale des compos ce qu'est une mosquée
de bayonne donc s'il vous plaît gardez
un peu de mesure
soyez soyez plutôt à faire le ménage
devant devant vous et c'est cette
question dont vous ne parlez pas en même
temps de parler finissez loïc
prud'hommes et vous répondrai ensuite
gaëtan du sausset oui je voulais juste
terminée c'est aussi tous ces gens qui
nous qui nous montre du doigt pour
masquer leurs propres intérêts si je
pense au ministre de l'intérieur
précédent qui malgré tout l'arsenal
législatif qui existent n'ont rien fait
et aujourd'hui voudraient nous faire
porter le chapeau 2 responsabilités je
pense à monsieur valls ou à monsieur
cazeneuve donc tout ça est vraiment
assez odieux et en plus relève vraiment
de contrevérités et nous on a été je
vous dis constant constant sur nos
prises de position nous on fait bien la
différence entre l'obscurantisme et
l'islamisme et toutes les dérives de des
religions et de la radicalisation dans
toutes les religions et nous y sommes
tout à fait attentifs et nous prouve
nous prenons pour qu'il y ait le des
moyens qu'ils soient vraiment mis sur le
renseignement parce qu'on voit aussi que
cette affaire-là
et il semblerait d'après les éléments
que nous avons à cette heure et je vous
devrez cliquer condamne aussi le temps
d'analyser tout ça il s'en moque il ya
quand même un défaut du renseignement
intérieur à pouvoir signaler à pouvoir
tracer et à pouvoir croiser les fichiers
et les signalements entre l'éducation
nationale et le renseignement
territoriale 300 vols entre 3d récents
niveaux policiers pour leur enseignement
annoncé ce soir guettant du sausset vous
vouliez répondre à loïc prud'hommes vous
étiez
oui bien sûr juste un petit bout
d'ailleurs pour le renseignement on sait
bien qu'on renforce et qu'on continue à
soutenir on sait bien moralement
juridiquement que matériellement les les
renseignements il faut savoir font déjà
un travail excellent si on veut les
aider maintenant il fait suffit d'abord
devait être expulsé je le disais tous
les étrangers fichiers ça permettra déjà
de soulager un certain nombre d'heures
qu'ils comment dire qu'ils les mettent à
profit justement pour surveiller ces
personnes là qui te fait n'ont rien à
faire chez vous alors maintenant encore
une fois je suis désolé revient là
dessus mais je comprends qu'il toute une
partie de la classe politique y soit
très gênée d'avoir participé à des
manifestations et le ccf
mais pas seulement alors je oui à la
france insoumise d'ailleurs je crois
qu'il ya un certain nombre de personnes
lors de la manifestation république qui
vont réserver un accueil des plus
chaleureux parce qu'ils ne supportent
pas justement la contradiction qui est
la vôtre je pense que ce sont aussi vos
anciens alliés du parti socialiste qui
au moment où vous étiez allé manifester
à pas loin du bataclan encore une fois
avec les islamistes il ccf vous ont dit
que vous faisiez une erreur à ce moment
là ce n'est pas le rassemblement
national qui vous le dit ce sont vos
partenaires du parti socialiste mais
quand je vous disais vous n'êtes pas les
seuls
le parti socialiste lui même dès 2015
participer à un dîner de gala avec le
ccf
mais moi il ya d'autres choses qui
m'inquiètent indépendamment des prises
de position de parti politique qui
parfois peuvent évoluer en fonction des
tendances du moment c'est que si on
prend le cci ils sont intervenus par
exemple en 2016 dans 42 écoles avec
l'aval donc du ministère de l'éducation
nationale du moment avec l'aval des
académies scolaires etc
qu'est ce qui fait que qu'est ce qui
explique un moment donné dans ce pays on
est une administration de juridiction
qui laisse la place à des islamistes
dans nos écoles et qui trois ans quatre
ans après décide de dissoudre
l'association d une incohérence qui est
totale et j'espère qu'un jour maintenant
une enquête la chip pour savoir qui
allait cesser islamistes s'exprimer
auprès de gamins dans nos écoles alors
tout cas le ccf de son côté a réagi
regardez
depuis hier nous sommes la cible de
menaces de mort et d'une campagne de
haine qui exigent la dissolution du ccf
devant autant de calomnies d'une
incroyable indécence compte tenu du
contexte notre équipe reçoit un soutien
ccf grandissant merci du fond du coeur
alors loïc prud'hommes pour vous le ccf
c'est le bouc émissaire dans cette
terrible affaire où il a effectivement
une réelle responsabilité dans la mort
du professeur de l'enseignant je vous le
disais tout à l'heure il faut danser sur
ces sujets de terrorisme me regardait du
sang froid et ne pas agir sous le coup
de l'émotion
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a les
moyens de savoir si deux ccf respecte et
à respecter les lois de la république
c'est ces dernières années depuis depuis
sa création jusqu'à aujourd'hui et
l'arsenal est tout à fait suffisant et
donc moi je n'ai pas accès au dossier je
ne je n'ai pas les éléments et donc je
ne peux pas le dire ce qui il est
c'est pour ça qu'on disait qu'il fallait
absolument le respect de la loi et parce
que ce sera sans appel s'ils ont
enfreint la loi
il faut les interdire et point barre n'y
a aucune discussion à avoir là-dessus et
les sens je suis très clair par contre
il faut s'assurer que ya bien des
éléments factuels tangibles qui soit
conforme à nos lois parce qu'on ne peut
pas appliquer les mêmes méthodes que ce
que l'on prétend compact combattre à
savoir la vindicte et des choses qui
sont approximatives donc oui s'il y a
des éléments il faut il faut interdire
le ccis et voilà on le saura et invite à
garder aussi un peu de sang-froid et à
regarder le dossier sur la durée je
voulais revenir sur les moyens aussi
parce que cette affaire du ccf on le
voit est assez lié avec la sphère des
réseaux sociaux et de comment on a été
quand même confronté à cette vindicte
sur les réseaux sociaux il a été même
prononcé le terme de fatwas je pense
qu'il ya aussi le problème de
des moyens de la surveillance des
réseaux sociaux le leur la cellule
pharos qui s'occupe d'eux des
signalements sur les réseaux sociaux a
géré par an chaque année 280 milles
signalement et 28 agents 10000
signalement par agent ça fait plus de
cinquante par jour vous voyez bien qu'il
ya un petit souci à pouvoir surveiller
comment ces messages peuvent être
distillé les appels à la haine peuvent
être distillé sans que personne ne s'en
émeuve ne s'en rend compte
avant que l'inévitable l'horreur soit
soit commise et ça ça me paraît aussi un
élément important à prendre en compte
aujourd'hui il faut mettre ces moyens là
pour surveiller les réseaux sociaux je
vous rappelle que twitter ou facebook ne
sont ne sont pas des éditeurs ils sont
juste des hébergeurs et donc c'est alors
la puissance publique de faire respecter
la loi sur ces réseaux bien entendu
c'est auxerre pour conclure les réseaux
sociaux c'est eux qu'il faut montrer du
doigt finalement plus que le 6 et y est
fait est fait toutes ces associations
dans cette affaire selon vous non mais
si vous voulez qu'on responsabilise les
grands patrons de facebook twitter etc
ah oui évidemment et leurs règlements ou
leurs intérêts ne passe pas au dessus
des lois de la république puisque les
lois sur celles décidées par le peuple
et donc le peuple aurait que le peuple
mais maintenant encore une fois il faut
pas il faut il faut passer preuve de
retenue face aux dangers de l'islamisme
dans notre pays l'état de droit
évidemment encore une fois nous mais
c'est ce que je disais précédemment les
lois existent il faut les appliquer mais
il faut arrêter de tergiverser de
d'hésiter de ne pas vouloir y aller
est-ce que ça fait maintenant beaucoup
trop longtemps qu'il y à des attentats
dans notre pays il ya un problème avec
l'islamisme radical
si on prendre ne serait-ce que dans un
seul lieu de l'école y avait eu le le
problème du foulard de créer on a eu
ensuite suite aux attentats de 2001 des
enseignants qui déjà à l'époque d'alerté
qui avait des élèves qui criaient vive
ben laden dans les couloirs rien n'a été
fait y en a qui ont sorti des bouquins
ils ont été compétent blacklisté par
leurs collègues enseignants ou et
surtout par la hiérarchie scolaire
on se souvient des minutes de silence
lors des attentats de mohamed merah dans
certaines avaient été perturbés dans un
certain nombre d'écoles également le
mouvement pas de vagues
et là encore dernièrement on a des
témoignages a qui commencent à sortir un
peu plus parce que les langues se
délient et notamment professeur qui
disait que il avait étudié en cours et
les montres et des vidéos de pakistanais
qui brûlaient des drapeaux français
suite à la publication des caricatures
de mahomet par charlie hebdo et des
élèves se levait et applaudissait
alors quand est-ce qu'on va arrêter de
se cacher les yeux et qu'on va
véritablement agir contre ça donc
arrêtons d'hésiter arrêtons de
tergiverser trente six mille fois il ya
énormément de choses à faire à commencer
par évidemment la dissolution qui
s'essayait merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur notre
antenne merci à vous gaëtan du soc est
membre du conseil national du
rassemblement national
merci à vous loïc prud'hommes député la
france insoumise de la 3e
circonscription de gironde